des mesures de confinement qui se vivent
était également en allemagne
on va y retrouver par téléphone tout de
suite evelyne gebhardt cet eurodéputé
allemand d'europe écologie les verts
actuellement confiné evelyne gebhardt
bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france depuis l'allemagne
bonjour alors pour commencer comment ça
se passe votre confinement vous faites
du télétravail
racontez nous ben je fais du télétravail
j'ai beaucoup de choses à lire donc je
n'ai pas toujours le temps de le faire
maintenant je peux le faire d'une
manière approfondie j'ai des contacts
réguliers avec mes assistants qui sont
en confinement aussi et pourquoi ce
qu'il ya à faire donc
le travail continue et d'une tout à fait
toute une toute autre manière que celle
que nous avons l'habitude de faire à une
atmosphère particulière aux viens de
l'entendre globalement comment le vivent
vos concitoyens allemand ben les
concitoyens elle non ce ne sont pas
beaucoup
peut-être différent des citoyens
français et je vois que par la fenêtre
des gens qui sont en train de
s'embrasser donc je pense que là aussi
c'est une une chose j'ai l'impression
que beaucoup de citoyens n'ont pas
encore réalisé exactement la portée de
ce qui se passe en ce moment et qu'il
vaudrait mieux vraiment ce consignes et
faire attention à ne pas contaminer les
autres parce que la situation n'est
vraiment très très compliqué très
difficile et on devrait s'attaquer aussi
vite que possible alors de tulle
allemagne comment est ce qu ont ces
mesures un strict qui viennent d'être
dévoilées pour la france on est elle
perçue honte et vont elles étaient
perçus pardon en allemagne une chose
normale
une chose normale dans ce contexte on
nous demande en allemagne aussi de
rester chez nous de faire en sorte de ne
pas se déplacer autant que possible les
magasins sont fermés aussi sauf pour
l'alimentation pour les deux pour les
sens ma fille et certains autres donc
éviter c'est une compréhension tout à
fait totale que nous avons et je pense
que cela pourrait arriver en allemagne
aussi dans ces prochains jours si nous
nous rendons compte qu'il n'ya pas
d'autres jeux pas d'autre possibilité
que ça effectivement on constate à une
forte augmentation des cas en allemagne
mais beaucoup moins de morts comment est
ce que vous le comprenez à ça je ne
comprends pas je ne fais pas à quoi cela
revient on ya plus de contaminer en
france qu'en allemagne donc qu'il y ait
plus de morts chez ses
c'est possible je pense que ce que nous
avons fait en allemagne là commence
d'ailleurs ça était d'essayer de
d'aplatir de la la courbe de maladie et
je pense que en allemagne on a fait dès
le début on a demandé à ne pas faire
attention à ce que les personnes plus
âgées ne soit a soit restent somme ne
soit que les enfants ne pas voir de
leurs grands-parents et des choses comme
ça ça a été fait depuis le début parce
que la mentalité dans ce domaine c'est
justement les les personnes à risques
les plus âgés ceux qui ont des maladies
dues à cette maladie est donc on a fait
très très attention à cela qu'elle était
alors comment fonctionnent les hôpitaux
chez vous à ce qu' il y a des des
médecins des personnels hospitaliers qui
tire la sonnette d'alarmé
comment est-ce que cela marche en ce
moment du côté de l'allemagne
dans les hôpitaux nous avons installé
des services spéciaux justement pour ces
cas parce qu'il faut et les cas de
contamination il faut essayer que soit
fait à l'intérieur des hôpitaux
il y avait dans les dents tous les laïcs
rage dans toutes les constitutions si
vous voulez il ya des numéros de
téléphone spécial adressé pour demander
rongeait ceci j'ai cela est ce que vous
pensez que je vais me faire tester et
donc et et on demande aux gens de ne pas
aller dans les hôpitaux directement de
ne pas aller chez le médecin directement
justement pour éviter la contamination
du personnel médical et de faire en
sorte que dès le début on sache est ce
que cette personne qui sont peut-être
enrhumé qui ont une certaine puis ceux
qui ne se sentent pas trop bien est ce
que c'est vraiment de corona ou est ce
que ce n'est pas autre chose le qui est
moins grave
les personnes que vous dites est ce que
vous nous dites les personnes qui ont
les personnes suspectes les cas sus pour
tout cas sont aujourd'hui testé en
allemagne oui oui ils sont ici en
allemagne
la température est ce que vous touchez
et est ce que vous venez les rayons a
qui sont qui sont le plus d'attentes et
d'un frais là on fait automatiquement
inclus
merci merci à vous et evelyne gebhardt
avoir répondu à nos questions directes
sur rt frange rappelle que vous êtes
eurodéputée allemande europe écologie